I am Joe Wiesenthal co-host of what you
missed today's chart i'm looking at
shows how big global ramifications of
the chinese devaluation so what you have
here is the yellow line and this is the
chinese un versus the euro as you can
see since china devalued its currency un
has plunged in recent days against the
euro the white line is the stock chart
of LVMH the big European luxury goods
maker that sells alcohol and fashion two
countries around the world one of their
huge customers is China because they
take advantage of the emerging Chinese
upper middle class and the rich well so
their stock has been plunging because
now their goods are more expensive for
Chinese consumers and the currency that
they get from those Chinese consumers
isn't worth as much as you can see that
as soon as the Chinese currency plunged
so too did the stock of LVMH it's a
fascinating example of how this whole
thing is rippling across the world
that's my color chart watch what do you
miss at four pm eastern time